it's early in the morning and rush hour
in this Berlin kitchen they've already
got hundreds of orders to prepare the
founders of startup green guru spied a
gap in the market a salad shaped gap
they cater to health-conscious urban
professionals who are too busy to make
their of lunch people expect things to
be fast they want instant gratification
they want to have everything at the
touch of a button that's especially true
at lunchtime when people are really busy
so these show that in Germany two out of
three people consider healthy eating
important the trend is reflected in
supermarket sales demand for wholesome
fresh smoothies and juices is soaring
as a Deloitte is and people are more
concerned now about products being fresh
and organic old-fashioned ready meals
that are full of additives and
preservatives aren't as popular as fresh
produce honey Brook each person the
ready meal segment is stagnating
manufactures are struggling Nestle is a
market leader and currently investing
heavily in research they want to provide
nutritional solutions for consumers
based on their genetic makeup and
medical history a custom-made diet for
better health the head of Nestle Germany
predicts this will be the next big thing
there's no one-size-fits-all for healthy
eating personalized diets mean what you
eat depends on your body type your age
your gender and a number of other
parameters as in feet of power method I
buy food manufacturers are also
branching out with online nutritional
advice services in return they get to
suss out precisely who's eating what
for the time being the statistics mainly
reflect rough averages for example
Germans eat on average 60 kilos of meat
each per year but these days a growing
number of Germans are switching to
vegetarian diets and one in a hundred
Germans is vegan the number of vegans
has risen in recent years veganism is in
the middle of a boon and is getting a
lot more attention the numbers might
soon plateau a bit but looking to a
sustainable future we believe veganism
is a trends that will continue to grow
but butchers beg to differ they're
convinced that vegans and vegetarians
are only a small minority and say
they'll always be a demand for meat our
customers are still eating meat they're
eating less of it but they wanted to be
better quality
Green Guru has a few salads left over
from this morning the delivery service
makes a point of throwing away as little
as possible
that's where another startup rescue
comes in it tackles food waste with
technology so far in Europe they've
managed to rescue 100,000 meals destined
for the garbage rescue is an online
platform rescue is an online platform
that allows private individuals to order
meals from restaurants and cafes that
would otherwise have gone to waste and
they're sold at a discounted price it's
all about reducing waste we save about
thirty thousand kilos of food in Europe
this way maybe another solution would be
to only produce food on demand one day
dinner might come out of a 3d printer
then we'll decide what we want to eat
with the click of a button Bon Appetit
you
[Music]